(applause)
- All right, y'all.
We have reached the end of the hour,
but I have but I have one
more uplifting story to share.
This is What I'm Liking.
(energetic music)
If you can see it, you can be it.
That's the idea behind a line
of female firefighter dolls.
These are so cute.
They were created by an actual firefighter
who says girls used to approach her
saying they didn't know women
could actually do this job.
It motivate, I love these dolls.
It motivated her to design dolls like this
that would inspire
girls from an early age.
We have her on the line right
now watching on NBC Miami.
Everybody, please say
hello to Lt. Tina Guiler
of the Miami-Dade County Fire Rescue.
(audience applauding, cheering)
- [Kelly] Hello!
- Hi, Kelly.
- I love these dolls!
Oh, my God, my girl is going to love this.
Have you seen the impact
that the dolls have made?
- Yes, I have.
I designed them, like you said,
because I still have little
girls coming up to me
saying, "Are you really a firefighter?"
or, "I didn't know girls
could be firefighters."
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- So, I thought, how am
I going to get this out
to little girls to know that
they can be firefighters, too?
- Yeah.
- [Tina] So, that's why
I designed the doll.
And they've been going out to kids
and I've had a mom actually come up to me
and she said, "I have
to tell you this story
about my daughter."
And I go, "Okay."
And she goes, "My daughter came up to me
and told me that she wanted to be a boy."
And she goes, "Why do you
want to be a boy, honey?"
And she goes, "Because I
want to be a firefighter,
and you have to be a boy
to be a firefighter."
So, that just broke my heart and I said,
"Okay, this is the impact
that I'm changing with these dolls."
- Yeah, absolutely.
What you just said is so
powerful and such great messaging
for kids that you can be
anything, girl or boy.
I heard that you're
working on other projects,
as well, though, right?
- [Tina] Yeah, so, I have
three of these dolls, okay?
That's Molly that you're holding there,
and Molly is named after Molly Williams,
who is the first known female firefighter
in the United States back in 1815,
so I wanted to dedicate
this doll to Molly Williams
and her service to the fire service.
She was a really good firefighter,
and I just wanted to dedicate it to her.
And the other two dolls'
names are Ash and Ember.
And those are just fire
reference names so that you can -
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- ...be a little firefighter.
But these dolls actually promote
to help other firefighters in need,
such as cancer, on-the-job injuries.
So, I started a foundation
called the Triple F Foundation
and I myself beat breast cancer.
So, I wanted to help other firefighters
that might be going through the same.
- Well, congratulations -
- [Tina] So that's what that -
- ...one, on beating breast cancer,
and two, thank you so
much for your service
and what you do for us.
(applause)
- [Kelly] Thank you so much.
There are no words, really.
I'm liking your post right
now, and that's not all.
Our season-long partner,
Pilot Pen, makers of G2,
the go-to pen of the Kelly Clarkson Show,
love what you're doing to
support female firefighters,
so they're going to be
writing Triple F a check for $1000.
How's that sound?
(applause)
- Oh, my gosh, that's amazing. Thank you.
- [Kelly] No, thank you so much, Tina,
once again, for your service.
Thank you.
And thank you to all
our guests this hour -
(audience cheering)
- ...Darius Rucker, Nikki Glaser,
Ava Paige, and Lawrence Zarian.
Y'all have a great day,
and if it's not, try and change it.